You can finally live openly as an anime otaku.The
special feeling that secret otakus have is gone.Japanese
food is very healthy.You'll be living next door to Seven, so it wo
n't be much different than before.There are Japanese people who want to date foreigners.  There are
n't many people out there who would make a good lover.Japan is
full of advanced technology.In the 1980s, everything was clean and
well-organized.There's mandatory cleaning,
so I can finally go to Tower Records in Shibuya.
Wait a minute,
let alone a record player, you don't even have a CD player.Japanese
people are often very clean.Americans
like you, whose faces are oily and shiny, are
very conspicuous.Anyway, prices are
low and wages are low.Japanese UF.  Catcher is
really fun.The first 5 episodes are
like HELLK.I can
finally go to the JPOP live I've always wanted.If I buy a ticket from Tebaya for 3 times the
price, even a foreigner can work in the anime industry.If I do
well in the anime industry, I
feel like I want to work there.
Generally speaking, Japanese people
are very healthy. Generally speaking, Japanese affairs are too
expensive and there are too few facilities.  It's
quite difficult to read high-level kanji,
but once you master them, your reading speed will go up a lot.Without
katakana, Japan would be much safer than other countries.  You'll be
living in a house made of wood.The morning
trains are always on time and always
crowded to death.If you're in trouble, you can use your Gaijin Card.If they find out you're using a Gaijin Card, you'll
have to commit Harakiri.
Variety shows are the funniest variety shows in the world.Even if you're not interested, you
still have to pay for a TV stand.Japan isn't as civilized as America yet,
but its politics are already just as
rotten.If you move to the countryside, it's really
free.  It takes
about 10 million yen and 3 years to turn an empty house into a livable home.
Modern toilets in Japan are truly amazing.
Modern toilets in Japan are used in restaurants where they are most needed, namely izakayas and ramen shops.  There are four beautiful seasons in Japan,
and there are
illnesses in each season such as hay fever, influenza, and cold/temperature allergies.In
Japan, health insurance is shockingly low, and
taxes are shockingly high.So
when I moved to Japan, I learned Japanese every day.  There
is only one conversation that can be used